good morning believe nation if you are
struggling with how to be memorable how
to make sure that you are on top of
everybody's mind and they never forget
your name I'm going to share a great
clip with you from Grant Cardone that I
think will help when I go into an
interview to get a job I don't come out
without a close they'll either hire me
on the spot or they'll regret not hiring
me you might not hire me but I promise
you you will regret not harm me and are
you'll say dude who was that cat who was
that God that just came in here so while
this clip is about getting an interview
and getting a job and that may not be
your interest as an entrepreneur the
important message here is you need to be
memorable because you may not be
interviewing for a job but you are
interviewing with clients right when
clients are talking to when media is
talking to you when potential employees
are talking you big suppliers are
talking to you you are selling yourself
and you need to be memorable and being
memorable means being yourself having a
strong opinion standing for something
being passionate being excited so that
after somebody walks away from a meeting
with you they're going to love you
they're going to love that energy and
creativity everything you threw into it
or they're not going to love you right
you don't want to be in that middle
ground that boring zone you want to
leave that lasting mark I'm reminded of
the story of ty warner who's the founder
of the beanie babies franchise and
became a multi-billionaire and in his
early days he used to show up for
meetings with potential retailers who
could sell his products wearing a top
hat and a fur coat and a cane and a
briefcase and people used to always
wonder what's in the case who was a
strange guy walking in like it or hate
it he made a lasting impression he was
memorable now I'm not suggesting you
have to get all dressed up and you gotta
make this persona you got to make
everybody curious and maybe think you're
a little bit crazy but you do have to do
something that makes you memorable and
makes you stand out so my question of
the day for you today is what makes you
memorable I'd love to hear it in the
comments below what the people remember
for you for how are you different
sharing
the comments I'd love to see it and I
think it could also help inspire the
other entrepreneurs who are watching if
you liked this video and you want to see
more don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and the newsletter thank you so
much for watching continue to believe
and i'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of entrepreneurship to
kick start your day on the right foot